the humane society of the united states
is carrying out its largest animal
rescue ever
four thousand beagles four thousand are
being removed from a virginia breeding
operation that's accused of violating
animal welfare laws many of the dogs
were set to be sold to labs for
experiments and now they're in desperate
need of homes manuel bergus tagged along
with volunteers who are trying to make
that happen quickly
here we go
one by one they are carried out of this
van nervous yes but finally in the arms
of volunteers at homework trails in
fairfax station virginia who want to
nurture them
and as executive director sue bell says
let them just be dogs having their feet
on the grass for the first time ever the
first time ever first time ever these
dogs have not touched a surface that
hasn't been rubber since they were born
you're seeing them getting to run and
hop they've never done that before
they've never seen a toy they've never
sat in a lap so it's a whole day of
firsts for them the day includes
assessing the dog's health and needs the
inspection reveals the series of letters
and numbers tattooed inside their ears
by the breeders to identify them the
puppies that were born
they would stay until a certain age and
then be put in plastic crates and sent
either by truck or by airplane to
research facilities where they would
then spend their life in a cage
undergoing any number of
medical or scientific research projects
video taken during a months long
undercover operation by people for the
ethical treatment of animals or peta
shows the cumberland virginia breeding
facility run by research company envigo
the department of justice sued the
company alleging it was failing to
provide humane care and treatment to the
thousands of beagles in a settlement
last month the company agreed to shut
down the facility though it did not
admit wrongdoing the irony of that is
that these beagles are the lucky ones
that were living in inhumane conditions
because
the conditions were inhumane enough to
warrant this intervention from the
department of justice kirsten peake is
with the humane society of the united
states
how are you moving 4 000 dogs
yeah so we are moving the approximately
four thousand dogs in batches
[Music]
we're picking them up on a rolling basis
three to five hundred at a time
and so some of them come to the humane
society of the united states care and
rehabilitation center some go
directly to shelter and rescue partners
like the ones brought to homework trails
where sue bell hopes the attention the
beagles are getting helps bring people
to shelters full of other dogs in need
once they're in the shelter then it's
our job to introduce them to all the
different types of dogs we have and most
people are just looking for a really
good family dog which is what andrea
justice may just have found we don't
need more dogs you know we have two but
we have plenty of room in our hearts and
our house
and there are more beagles on the way
that's because volunteers are only
halfway done removing them from that
facility so there are hundreds more dogs
to go
anwa jorquez cbs news fairfax virginia
you know who does not have enough dogs
nate burleson exactly
honey i hope you're watching there's 4
000 of those beagles we got to get one
and beagles are small they're docile
they're patient which unfortunately is
why they're so prized and researched
i do not oh wow we have a dog dad is
holding firm against the kids on this
one oh man